I am Greg Alba people this is Lauren
Francesca from I want my Lauren on
YouTube and everything else that is a
social media thing MySpace
today it's the only old one I remember
you saw my face
I mean it's not this got sent over to us
top 10 celebs dissed by Eminem from a
channel I really enjoy watchmojo.com and
I'm surprisingly amount of people don't
really like them as much anymore I don't
know why I really like them mmm I always
say people ask my favorite musicians
favorite band
Red Hot Chili Peppers mmm
I can do the fast part of rap God can
hear it you gotta use into that and that
comes down like four minutes into it
okay I'll post like a little snippet of
it online never bitter ones name say the
sample meal good take all let's go Jake
and he shamelessly dings - lemon I love
Marshall calm if they are cutting down
our picks for the top 10 - let's dip my
M&M pages quick reminder if you like
this video be sure to Riley Harry hit
subscribe for more later on yeah all
right for the pan we're going F in pop
culture figures that receives a time for
a miracle woman from one Marshall
Mathers in his satirical 2009 celebrity
take down Eminem take some people's
habits several superstars devoting a
whole verse to Kim well specifically he
raps about her religious Maximus while
also questioning her gender remember I
got an email from a friend of mine and
she's like oh you made it
I mean I was rapping to value given the
playful tone of the track exclude that
ends not on the warpath against
America's beloved reality star but she
does seem intrigued by the shipment so
as I said drop even having her comically
exaggerated posterior makings fall over
in the songs music video
it's not the most poignant demin embers
ever written but it's clearly it is that
slim shadey wanted to get off his Jeff
you know she's the biggest fan of yours
and she's very excited I don't know
she's going to be honored with the whole
Trump I heard that one like that wall
built that wall fill that wrong while
normally focusing his distract on
celebrities and other entertainers and
isn't one to shy away from politician
over Donald Trump first up flips wrap in
October 2016
with his tracks campaign speech where he
called out trumpet someone knocked it to
the presidential rule you say Trump
don't kiss that like a puppy because he
runs his campaign but its own cache for
the funding and that's what you wanted
in loose cannons blunt but at an on the
button who doesn't have to answer to no
one the insults continue this is not
money Sean strap no favors where and
explains how he plans to ruin Trump's
breath man time okay no government hang
like a mango Joe Kane don't want it
slips up [ __ ] I'll make you talk don't
[ __ ] up the track also take famous
bright media personality and cult
reminding audiences with a list of ways
to make these two figures disappear
itself and Coco with a clamp oh so when
I ramped up the handle suck my damn foot
cut up while he may joke around a lot
it's clear that mmm takes politics
seriously ladies and gentlemen our great
candidate Flynn yay no break
Pamela Anderson my name is doctor said
it was a lot worse of channel asleep
Rock Network the second boat was a
defining figure of the 1990s but she
didn't quite say relevant however
unluckily for her she's a born 100 lire
a one Eminem stepson that means all
family [ __ ] job that's like this ha for
his Grammy award-winning dad Eminem
offer - our commentary on panelist Davis
implants using some aggressive lyricism
before referencing the early nineties
hip-hop duo criss cross and their
fashion sense if we can only get a look
at what it's a clever Eminem disc and
blurred the lash allow him to make some
noise in pop culture that's a year
Pam actually downside to our implants
meanwhile wide rose to stardom
partially why would you do that goober
off number seven Elvis Presley without
me you ain't just like the awkward
phrasing of this pop culture dish it's a
sharp one nonetheless if you didn't
already know is it it we built his
career on rhythm and blues and Eminem
reminded us of that back with his 2002
single talisman out 51st make reference
to the king in verse 2 only to compare
himself to said king in verse 3 noting
how they similarly reappropriation
commutable Chara and faced similar fate
just limited to the section climbing
finale the Johanna vital he used to the
hip hop industry they were pretty minion
otherwise no matter how many facing the
user will do exactly both amp and Elvis
significantly affected pop culture but
in different ways
[Music]
Michael Jackson something like that was
pretty painful as an Irish to another
eyes I chasing a miss bikini pump in his
2004 Billboard hits then touches on the
trolling scandal Michael Jackson faced
as well as the dark side of celebrity
Fame with this aggressive disc Eminem
drops a safety net - and he makes a
direct reference to the child
molestation charges while claiming not
to specifically have jack - then again
Eminem took it even further in his music
video which resulted in Jackson calling
Steve Harvey's radio show to address the
issues but surprisingly there was plenty
of backlash against Eminem even from the
likes of Stevie Wonder but it's just
another case of flint causing a stir oh
yeah okay fine insane clown posse
Marshall Mathers
you know that ain't never played in all
arena like this didn't dig they never
did no [ __ ] this big before for a bit of
context the view between Slim Shady and
ICP extent before Eminem was even a
household name run and preemptively
announced that the duo would perform an
on launch for the slip JEP without
asking them
[Applause]
thank you in a stadium good thing that
resulted in a lot of name-calling and
thinly veiled parodies like mmm slim
eNOS all the games I messed up once
Eminem had more exposure he took the
opportunity to lyrically shame the clams
emcees with a rather smaller board first
but here's what famous it's a frank bake
with me every moment some clown so they
look Quinn M&M jabs when his car driver
I am here with queer pointy twin engines
when the rap duo sprayed an audience
with soda this was lemon em what I
promise you they're so straight for the
job with most of his second verse
devoted to insulting mileage a and
Shaggy 2 dope it's evident that Jamie
had a lot to get off his chest look at
you all run in your mouth again can we
see them now right yeah I love that
movie now make up when they try to fan
me with me nails
naina and what absolutely to talking
about of that before movie without me oh
yeah Toby do you stop IOP your old boy
you don't know me usual sex go without
but nobody doesn't detect no when three
our packs a wallop after calling out in
sync member Chris Kirkpatrick is limp
Biskit Eminem roasts popular New York
City DJ Moby
[Music]
the Ryan captures a specific time and
place with mm shouting out to OB tries
to beat uploaded it all stems from
Robi's criticism of mm at the 2001 grand
a content of Eminem's lyrics is likely
homophobic sexist and racist which could
then be misinterpreted by impressionable
younger audiences seriously how can we
go to a 36 year old bald-headed guy I
mean first of all you're 35 aren't you
they're not start you think it's good
that Moby rattle never never fit since
his without beef lamb in trevenant
fashion called LT electronic artist as
gang Moby not only didn't find the
reference though but he said he gave him
some amazing free publicity
oh well the movie girl threw me analyze
over lady number three for these beers
marshallmatters
time thanks we bring it on to killing
the mini started Congrats can't sing and
bringing zombies in yet another timely
jab from em self-titled track he proved
that he was not a fan of the
turn-of-the-century Posse at the time of
release boy bands were everywhere oh
yeah I remember those days
Oh Britney I love our kids flinching
ladypau vibes by referencing the actual
cost of a compact disc did you tell what
it is
charging back mixing down to the podium
let's put off the B word on poor sweet
Britney which given his reputation
probably let her off lightly but I mean
I'm kinda also admitted that he bought
one of her albums so take what you will
from that I'm keeping it gangster homie
I'm keeping it Gabriel number two
Christina Aguilera the real Slim Shady
why that cherry ocean covering never
been in quit the elaborate and revealing
verbal beatdown
Eminem can trust this cloth superstar in
a special on MTV's or her hit what a
girl wants Aguilera praise Eminem pretty
much and took issue with how she got
into his personal life
mm yeah totally the girl that he talks
about killing on his record actress so
it's called for an immediate is being
that Christina's love life is the next
across the bay we can friend um we're
more people she gave me a cube is Merida
can take it that's it you guys what
happened no that angular during her
performance of living it up later
claiming to have done it quote all for
the nookie number one happy right since
that Sina rose to fame through MTV and
Carson Daly show Total Request Live Slim
Shady you sing wake that perhaps there's
more to the story there to learn against
retaliation comes fast and hard when
you're on marshallmatters leo I find
what he has to say disgusting it is
completely untrue before we unveil our
topic here if you wanna mention one
variety rebel morning didn't expected it
go whoop it up God thought about her I
mean in a wedge that he hooked up with
Mariah Carey
however the globe icon wouldn't admit it
Hannah Terry released a song titled
obsessed with several thinking that it
was her way of adding fuel to the fire
that Eminem had sent with bagpipes from
Baghdad even possibly impersonating him
to the songs music video
a month then give the warning shot Chris
get it this is a blatant pariah District
Commission claimed to have edited their
guys we should just like I've been going
off on you all the time but no reason
throw you out down the hall the gun
check you wanna look at the mm from all
the one like a concluding round think
about you all the time I think it is
funny when I have to one of us excessive
in nature exactly different than
clowning on ICP vanilla ice or even
Elvis Presley out this track obviously
makes for juicy conversation amongst pop
culture obsessives they did not have a
physical relationship in him do you
agree with our tics check out these
other great clip which oh and subscribe
for new single every day oh dude my boy
Eminem wow he's such a fast rapper now I
imagine kind of like getting beat up by
the flash you might not understand this
reference Lauren thank you TV show the
flash yeah like comic characters
well Indies so fast like there's this
game called injustice where when the
flashes this combo movie hits you so
many times the other character doesn't
feel it and then suddenly he feels at
all at once yeah and that's kind of how
mm is now when he does songs he's like
that whole song he made about dance
Donald Trump they came out this year
he's so fast at time and his insults are
so clever that a lot of the time I'm
just like I don't know what you're
saying
I am a thank you yeah I feel all the
disco minutes that's how he raps and I
really I don't know what you said my
feelings are hurt listen anymore do you
I you know what I honestly I had I think
even real like he's making new music
yeah or stuff hasn't been on the radio
you know it's all the old stuff well his
last song wouldn't fill with a lot of
like fun
radio songs is like normally every album
has like that one song that's going to
be a popular radio hit you know like my
name is real Slim Shady without me I'm
just scared to say anything bad I don't
want to ever know a famous I don't want
to gosh and saying yeah I just I'm gonna
fail pathes Thank You Smith Ames great I
followed his daughter Haley on Instagram
and she grew up to be beautiful really I
want to
she looks like she's gorgeous I was like
I don't think I've ever asked that girl
out even if she was interested in
retailing I would be so scared to date
Eminem daughter nothing wow oh my god
she's beautiful all right
she's the one on the right yeah she's so
pretty see and she's dating this guy
know who that is or you're one brave
soul my friend singer I have no idea I
don't want anything about I feel like
even knowing slept about a would have
said I mean I don't want to do any
better
I feel like in an Eminem [ __ ] lists
would be the worst thing you could
possibly do for yourself yeah it's like
I can read a hundred thousand hate
comments about me on YouTube one line
from Eminem I am destroying it early we
love you man no this video really didn't
show her like over my eyes up - holy
crap he has insulted a lot of a balloon
yeah but it seems like everyone insulted
came at him yeah I've been for all those
insults which is pretty interesting most
me Michael ratney it's like Michael
Jackson did some stuff that a lot of
people made fun of him on until yeah man
we did it like originated insulting
Michael Jackson but like the up in smoke
tour I didn't know anything about that
like I love that song Marshall Mathers I
didn't know what a reference I do a lot
about the Mariah Carey stuff how I kept
saying like oh we were dating but he had
a bad day in that song he he loops in
audio d threatens to be like I have I
have recordings of the audio recordings
and he loops in some recordings of her
talking to him really yeah here it's
like saying I'll release these if you if
you keep denying this yeah I didn't know
why everyone after Christina but then
seeing that footage of her talking about
him she is pointing out a fact that he
was married at the time to that woman
that he was in the kim huiae was hoping
the one in his songs but she did it in
kind of a mocking way i'm just gonna
take him an m side sway and i'm called
me a [ __ ] that's true I'm just gonna go
that rep it was the way she said it that
made it insulting it wasn't a pit wasn't
what she said but how she likes are
laughing at him about that Pamela
Anderson got a breast reduction because
of him that's what I think so
Wow because that's what Eminem was
becoming like he's really hot
my name is but then real Slim Shady was
when he was like she's superstar now and
when that came out yeah maybe put a
Pamela Anderson this is like pretty
YouTube yeah where everyone is that
because now that you're on YouTube
everyone's like you just expect hate
part of the territories part of the
world and I think when you're you know
being shown like rapper song and folded
like that and then you're getting
exposed to social media comments about
your kids - oh yeah their kids are
ecstatic you so well let's hope they get
breast reduction surgery - thanks for
watching mojo comm I watch a lot of your
movie lists actually you can subscribe
to the real rejects subscribe to
watchmojo.com youtube follow her there
and patreon.com is a website where you
can get needs just go just go I'm sick
of sages mentioning trust me it's worth
it even where you know for just the
dollar ones there's plenty of rewards
okay trust me
geez smile for the camera
but the he was really upset there Oh
[Music]